donc en résumé, je suis au courant des choses et
je suis là pour vous apprendre une leçon précieuse
quelle leçon je vous donnerai quand
je comprendrai que
[Musique]
vous ressemble  Ce n'est pas fini ici après
tout, je vais prendre Stacy et
gérer la situation de Jimbo dont
vous êtes responsable, appelez-moi quand vous l'avez
contenu, ne me comprenez pas, alors le
bébé musclé géant travaillait avec la
manière des robots tueurs  on s'en fout d'entrer et de
trouver mon petit garçon qu'as-tu fait quoi
[Musique]
tu es un menteur atroce mais ce n'est pas
ce que j'appelle à propos de la maison animée
est entourée bizarre d'envoyer la
balançoire pour bébé comme une distraction dont j'ai besoin  vous devez
scanner le grand tableau et nous trouver une issue de secours
tic-tac Templeton la situation est à
des niveaux de crise ici Stacy comment va le
quartier ok j'ai une idée et
j'ai une crise Weiner moi où est ma
voie d'évacuation j'ai trouvé plus de biscuits et de
boîtes de jus  Templeton Templeton où
es-tu j'ai perdu le contact bloque la porte
nous c  Je pourrais arrêter cette période de deux ans
et faire attention non, ils ne peuvent pas me renvoyer
à la garderie oh Dieu merci,
sortez de la route Templeton dès que possible ou depuis que j'ai un
scooter, je peux simplement le renvoyer à ses
parents Oh, cette situation est un
baril de poudre et  ce bébé est le
chalumeau que vous avez envoyé maintenant je sais que
dans ce quartier j'aimerai encore jamais les
bébés je l'interdis absolument attendez
où êtes-vous en ce moment
[musique]
Templeton vous nous avez tous condamnés
scooter
[musique]
Stasi organiser une réunion scooter pourquoi avons-
nous cette conversation votre travail est
une évidence vous agissez maman et
papa mignons vous donnent de la nourriture et un abri vous
doozy ils doozy comment pouvons-nous déplacer l'
aiguille sur cette touche de bus me parler
que faites-vous  dire des choses sordides sur notre
mère mieux tu ne sais pas
je vois que nous émettons un rappel ramène-les
au tribunal des bébés emmène-le tu
ne peux pas faire ça je pensais que nous étions censés
l'aider Stacy j'aime la
résolution de problèmes et  manque de morale mais
les enfants sont de la glace dont nous n'avons pas besoin  des
mesures drastiques qu'est-ce que je t'ai
appris papa Templeton je te dois une faveur j'ai perdu tout
intérêt après que tu m'ai promis des cookies
c'est toutes les affaires nous avons juste besoin de
savoir ce que veut le scooter busky clé de bus
faisons des affaires qui étaient de l'
argent dur vous maniaque
vous